[Aplausos]
este verano he tenido la gran suerte de
poder viajar a mallorca es una isla
preciosa con playas de revista hacía
muchísimo calor y todas nos moríamos por
meternos en el agua yo también lo hice
pero un día me llevé un susto de muerte
cuando vi que a mi lado había una medusa
las medusas son uno de los animales que
más miedo me da o sea que para mí contra
más lejos mejor pero me la quedé
observando durante unos segundos y me di
cuenta de que no era una medusa era una
bolsa de plástico una bolsa de plástico
y qué asquito pero bueno me olvidé de
ella y seguí nadando y al cabo de un
rato me di cuenta de que esa bolsa no
estaba sola estaba acompañada por otros
trozos de este material
salí indignadísima del agua pensando que
gente más como puede ser no no
pensé ni en que tenemos que ser más
respetuosos con nuestro medio ambiente
ni pensé en que pobres peces
pensé hipócritas hipócritas por
quejarnos de la existencia del plástico
y aún así seguir usándolo
y ahí estaba yo echándole la culpa a
otros seres humanos cuando un
pensamiento se me vino a la cabeza y me
persiguió casi como un fantasma
yo también uso plásticos
yo también colaboró a que haya un
continente más grande que francia
flotando en el pacífico hecho de
plásticos
yo también colaboró a que fue una marina
asfixiada por este material
y en ese momento me lo llame a mí misma
hipócrita
y sabéis que es lo más hipócrita que
podemos hacer lo más hipócrita de todo
llamarle a otra persona hipócrita porque
todos los somos todos
aunque no siempre no siempre porque no
todo el mundo cosa plásticos has sabido
que usar un vaso de plástico contribuye
a que este material acabe en el mar y
que nuestro planeta sean bullido por
plástico no siempre se nos ha enseñado
eso no siempre hemos sido conscientes de
que esas acciones ayudaban a ese
panorama que no nos gusta nada a ver
cuando nos llaman hipócritas nos están
dando realmente la oportunidad de abrir
los ojos de valorar nuestras acciones y
tomar los cambios que sean pertinentes
tenemos que hacer una introspección y
valorar nuestras acciones para poder
comenzar a mejorar o quedarnos igual
pero
no siempre tenemos que esperar a que nos
lo llamen levantados por favor todos
vale ahora vamos a hacer un ejercicio
muy sencillo que se lo va a durar un par
de minutos necesito que os agrupemos con
alguien que conocéis con aquellas
personas que hayáis venido por parejas y
estáis todos colocados genial vale
necesito que os miréis a la cara unos a
otros
mira la persona que tienes enfrente
a la cara a los ojos
y pregúntale en qué crees que soy
hipócrita pero tenéis que responder
tenéis que responder con sinceridad
[Música]
vale genial ya podéis volver a sentarnos
nuestras respectivas asientos
muchas gracias
no sé qué se habrán respondido vuestros
familiares o amigos que os acompañan
aquí pero hay un par de cosas que son
seguras y me encanta que haya escuchado
a gente reírse porque eso me ayuda a
confirmarlas
la primera que todos estamos vivos no
hay nada malo en preguntar si somos
hipócritas y no hay nada malo en
contestar a esa pregunta con sinceridad
la segunda es que ahora mismo ya estáis
un pasito más cerca de dejar de ser
hipócritas en ese aspecto de vuestra
vida a partir de ahora tenéis una
herramienta que os puede ayudar a
mejorar a seguir trabajando si acercamos
a ese estado de no hipócrita
a seguir trabajando
si hay que seguir esforzándose pero es
que precisamente ahí sale la mejor amiga
de la hipocresía la pereza
al fin y al cabo la hipocresía acaba
siendo la manifestación de la pereza que
produce luchar por aquello que queremos
porque para ello se necesita un esfuerzo
y romper con nuestra rutina
en ocasiones integramos en nuestro día a
día
acciones que acabamos confundido
confundiendo con necesidades cuando en
verdad son prescindibles
nos acostumbramos a llegar a la escuela
con un bocadillo envuelto en papel de
plata
pero no nos acostumbramos a cuestionar
nuestras rutinas nuestras acciones
porque van bien pues eso parece
pero que se desforesta en bosques se
miren montañas y se expulse a familias
de sus hogares es que funcione bien
yo no lo tengo tan claro
o qué me decís de cuando una mujer
embarazada por fin da luz y todos vamos
súper ansiosos a conocer a este nuevo
miembro de la familia y le decimos ay
qué bonito
a haber tres bien nacido
bonito lo que se llama bonito
no pero lo decimos porque es un momento
muy importante porque estamos dando la
bienvenida a un nuevo ser vivo a nuestra
familia después de nueve meses
y por aceptación social
y la aceptación social es hacer una
mejor amiga de la hipocresía
todos nosotros somos hipócritas todos
aunque no siempre
y no pasa nada no pasa nada si lo
reconocemos y trabajamos para dejar de
serlo
recibamos un eres hipócrita no como un
insulto sino como la oportunidad de
abrir los ojos la oportunidad de mejorar
esa oportunidad que nos da poder ver
nuestras acciones e iniciar un camino
que nos lleve a ese lugar en el que
deseamos estar
y creedme podemos llegar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]